no explanation necessary uh nico rosberg
is here with us uh well let me just say
a couple of things about it green tech
festival and extreme e-team owner it's
good to see you thanks for joining us
obviously we all remember you from
formula one tell us while you're here
um so i'm here for sports for climate
action uh from the united nations and
also representing sky uh we're working
together on on the sky zero uh ambition
um so it's a pleasure to be here and
very very interesting and i really hope
to to get a lot out of this and also to
have as much impact as possible by being
here a lot of people would say formula
one you use an awful lot of fuel
so how can you be green no that's true
of course yeah i know the sport still
has some way to go um but they're really
like making a big big effort at the
moment they just pledge to be
using 100 sustainable fuels by 2030
which then would be absolutely climate
neutral of course um so that is there's
a lot of good messages coming out now
they just banned completely one-way
plastic use in the in the paddocks like
saving one million bottles or something
like that so so it's really making a lot
of progress uh that's why i'm optimistic
and proud also that my spoil is doing
that and it's i think it's going in the
right direction sustainable fuel tell me
about that so sustainable fuel the
problem with sustainable fuel is that uh
of course you need to extract co2 from
the air in order to in order to produce
it um and that's still very
expensive very energy inefficient so it
can only be done in areas where there's
an abundance of renewable energies
available
and so for example there's a project in
chile which is uh which is being started
at the moment and it's going to take
some time that's why it's very ambitious
but one thing is for f1 to use
sustainable fuel but the second is how
can f1 play a role in helping mobility
at large uh embrace sustainable fuels
like for example emerging markets that's
a whole different challenge and that's
where i hope the sport can play a role
when you say
are we talking about synthetic fuel are
we talking about what i meant yeah it's
okay in the morning no no no no no no
absolutely and that's going to be better
than electric uh vehicles is it no no
ultimately electric vehicles are the way
to go definitely yes because there's
some arguments
which one is is the best way forward
yeah but electric cars are very energy
efficient you know and that's why that
is the way to go the problem is that for
emerging markets it's going to be maybe
decades i mean there's 1 billion
combustion engine cars on our roads
globally at the moment they won't just
disappear so if we can create a bridge
with synthetic fuels that could be
really really powerful
so that's what one needs to look at now
it's very ambitious again because i said
it's also the logistics to get the fuel
to the areas in the emerging markets big
big challenge
but maybe it's possible to really have
some impact i wonder how that would
convert to to formula one because we
love the roar of the engines don't when
it comes to formula one vehicles and
also the pit stops are very dramatic we
don't fill up with fuel anymore but but
that sort of that roar of an engine is
very much what we think about when we
think about formula one and with an
electric vehicle we're not going to get
that are we no you're right but you know
we have to there's always going to be a
little bit of a compromise when we're
making progress in the right direction
and with electric cars they're really
fun to drive because they accelerate
much better actually the combustion
engine cars because they have like
instant power instant torque four-wheel
drive they're really awesome
so there's a lot of benefits as well but
of course yes the v12 or v10 it gives
you goosebumps um and we're just going
to have to learn to live without that i
suppose okay um talk to me about formula
one i couldn't let you go without asking
you about the the uh races this season
and who's winning who isn't who might
likely take away the championship
yeah i mean it's exciting as as ever
it's unbelievable you know you have
these two best of their generations
going head to head
and max verstappen is really an
unbelievable form at the moment but
somehow i just believe that lewis with
his experience is gonna
somehow pull it his way in the very end
but it's i mean it's thrilling to watch
i'm glued to the television myself as a
fan um so it's i think it's gonna be a i
think five races to go now it's worth
everybody tuning in for that twelve
points ahead i think something like that
max not i'm not sure yeah something like
that
there are there abouts
but
lewis you know seems to when he's under
pressure he seems to slightly well not
slightly he blows up and and loses focus
potentially but you still think he's got
it in him
um who louis yes he's won his seven
championships
ahead by now it's difficult to say now
that he blows up under pressure it's
probably more uh max verstappen who has
more pressure because the first time
that he's in this situation and it's an
extreme situation to be in when you're
suddenly the favorite to win the
championship
you got to deal with that you know and
there's so much at stake um so it's
probably more on his side the pressure
and but for now he's dealing with it
unbelievably well okay i've just got to
ask this for my son who's a petrol head
and watches every race that i always ask
a question from him when we have you on
the show he's asking particularly about
the engines there's been all sorts of
engine issues this this season i think
i'm right saying they're only allowed
three um some are saying we need four
and one of one of the drivers has
already used uh valtieri as or abosas
has already used five engines is that
right
yeah that's true so they've done that to
reduce cost they've done that to reduce
the amount of resources that are
required um so that's why three engines
which again is in the right direction
but it makes it so challenging for the
for the teams because of course the
engines are high performance uh power
units you know and and to do a whole
season with them so they've been having
trouble with making it with just three
so i think lewis has also taken the
fourth one already max as well um but
now they should be fine and they should
get to the end and uh it's really just
pushing the boundaries of what's
possible uh trying to extract the
maximum performance whilst keeping them
reliable and i think they miscalculated
a little bit and got a bit wrong and
that's why there's been some engine
failures for most manufacturers so you
think maybe four next season no no
they'll because we're being green we
need to get no no definitely it has to
stay at three it will stay at three
and the manufacturers have to do an even
better job um but saying that also you
know with the hybrid power unit um that
is the most efficient engine there is in
the world at the moment in terms when
you look at the whole global footprint
of it um
especially within the first hundred
thousand kilometers that you do you know
it's more better than an electric engine
so it's also f1 has done a big
contribution in developing those hybrid
units which are now being deployed
across mobility at large in the world um
so there's a lot of good that formula
one has already done okay um just before
i let you go you asked me what i was
most looking forward to here what are
you most looking forward to
um i have my own sustainability event
actually it's one of the leading ones in
europe now it's called green tech
festival
and i'm meeting a lot of interesting
people because we have our event on
thursday friday in london this week
because we're going international with
it and i'm meeting a lot of people here
like gavin patterson from salesforce and
and doing some networking also preparing
for our event at the end of the week so
i'm i'm looking forward to most those
kind of encounters well thanks for
getting up early for us we appreciate it